-Seth Rogen's right.
The name actually is --
It is weird not hearing
Machine Gun Kelly.
-Yeah, is it odd now,
because you've become so famous
as Machine Gun,
that you're not Colson anymore?
-I was never -- I haven't been
Colson since I was 15.
Since I was 15 years old, I was
like, "I'm Machine Gun Kelly."
-Yeah. But Colson is just better
for when you're in movies?
-You know, Nickelodeon and
Disney don't like Machine Gun.
-Yeah, that makes sense.
That makes a lot of sense.
It's your first time
in the chair.
I'm so happy.
You've been here and performed.
-Yeah.
-By the way, I loved your --
I love your new album.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-It's fantastic.
Congratulations on it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I'm happy
that you're actually here
and sitting in the chair
and I get talk to you,
because, man,
you're really fun to talk to.
-Thanks.
-Talking with you backstage,
I mean, we have --
-I whispered something to you
one time when I performed here.
I was, like, "Dude, I love that
song 'Snowball Fight!'"
-I mean --
-Which was -- Jimmy had an album
I listened to a lot
in middle school.
It's --
-I probably didn't even believe
that you said that to me.
-If we replay it back,
you'll probably see me just slip
it to you and walk away.
But I was just like,
"Dude, I love that."
-"Snowball Fight!" --
I mean, that was, like --
-♪ Snowball, snowball ♪
♪ Snowball fight ♪
-Yeah, please -- No, really,
everyone loves that.
Please don't -- Please sit down.
-We'll add applause
later in post.
We both worked with
Cameron Crowe, which is cool.
How much do you love
Cameron Crowe?
-I love him so much that I
sent him a mean text.
-No.
-Yeah.
-To Cameron Crowe,
the nicest human?
-The nicest human.
The guy who actually
re-introduced me to my name.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Because of "Roadies"?
-Yeah, when I did
that show, "Roadies,"
I had a parking spot,
and it said "Colson."
And I, like, walked around, and,
all the guys, you know,
it would be like,
"Bob," and "Jimmy,"
and they'd be like,
"Hey, Colson," and whatever.
And I was like, "Man, I think
I like my real name again."
-That was Cameron that did that?
And you sent him a mean text?
-So, I have this thing
in my life where
I just, like, run everyone
away that loves me.
And, so, Cameron loves me,
and I have this thing where
I was like,
"You can't love me too much,
'cause I'm gonna run you away."
-Like a snap.
-So, I would
always call Cameron,
and he would always answer
and he would kind of just,
you know,
give me advice or,
you know, whatever.
And, so,
he didn't answer my call.
I think I called him
like three times,
you know, over a period of
like three days.
Called him three times,
he didn't answer.
And I texted him and I said,
"Oh, it's so punk rock
that you don't answer."
-Yeah.
-He never answered that.
-He never answered?!
That's even more punk rock!
-It's so punk rock. I know.
-It's even more.
Well, Cameron,
if you're watching,
we both love you.
-To be fair,
I sent him a follow-up text,
and I was like, "In case you
didn't get my humor,
I was just..."
-You do have a good sense of
humor, I will say.
Pete Davidson
was on our show recently,
and we talked about
you guys getting together.
And you fell off the stage
together at good-nights
at "Saturday Night Live."
-If you show that clip,
I am gonna...
-I would never.
Can we show --
-Oh, God. Okay.
[ Drumroll ]
-There you go. Watch this.
-Oh, God! Oh, no!
-Whoa!
-So, then -- So, I --
So, I go to Pete --
I go, "What happened?
What was that thing?
What happened with Machine Gun?"
And he goes,
"He had a bruised coccyx."
And I go, "What?"
He goes,
"He bruised his coccyx."
-It was bad.
-No, but I don't even know
what a coccyx is.
-I didn't know
what it was either
until the doctor was like,
"Well, you bruised your coccyx."
-Wait. Alright, so --
-Like three different X-rays
over in three different states.
I was like, "What's going --
Why can't I sit or stand
or do anything?"
They were like, "You see this
area here in your ass?
It's...
-Alright, so that's a coccyx.
-Yeah, it's your butt.
-How did you go about
bruising your coccyx?
-I was -- I had a match with
Post Malone in a beer-pong game.
And --
-As one does. Yeah, okay.
I think I've played beer pong
against Post Malone.
-And you know when you get
the cup and you start drinking?
-Of course.
-So, we didn't even
get to the game,
and I started drinking.
And, so,
they filmed on the way out.
They did, like, a "Rocky,"
like, boxing match,
like, you know,
film on the way out.
And I, like, couldn't take
the pressure of the camera,
so I was like, "Alright,
every five steps,
I got to do something cool,
'cause it's like 500 steps.
I don't just want to just walk."
So I was like,
"Got to do something.
So every five steps,
I'd be like...
And then there
was a staircase rail,
and I was like, "Yeah, great."
So I'd hit the staircase rail
and I rode it down.
At the bottom of it,
I didn't see a giant spike,
and it just, you know...
-Bruised your coccyx.
-Yeah, it rammed...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! Talk about --
-It did something
that was not --
-Yeah. Did you play it off?
-I -- I -- I --
-You played it off like
it was cool?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then this was also,
like, right when I was
starting to date,
you know, Megan.
And I, like --
I was holding it together.
It was just --
It was a bad night.
Like, the whole --
Like, I won the Ping-Pong match.
I went home.
I was like -- I had this --
Travis got me this --
He got me a knife that was --
that had an engravement from
the new album on it.
And I was like,
"Oh, check this out.
This is sick."
And I threw it up, and it came
and stuck in my hand.
Do you see that right here?
-I do see that.
-Yeah, that was from when
a knife stuck in my --
'Cause you know how
you throw it up
and you're supposed to catch it?
I looked at her and I was like,
"Check this out."
And I was like, "Ugggh!"
-She's like, "You are
the coolest dude
I've ever met in my life.
Kiss me!"
Wow!
-And then, the next morning,
as soon as she left,
I was like, "Yo,
I need stitches real quick."
-Yeah, like, "Dude, I got a
bruised coccyx over here
and a knife in my hand."
-A bruised coccyx
and a knife in my hand.
-Dude, that's so --
-Yeah, and so
I didn't have strength,
so when I picked Pete --
And, like, Pete is a --
He's a method person.
Like, he's always a different
shape every time I see him.
-Yeah, he is a little --
-He is.
He has different hair,
different -- He's like, "Dude,
I just worked out for
two months straight.
-Then he's
super-skinny and tall.
-Yeah. And, so, this time,
he was, like --
I showed up,
and he was sweating.
He was like, "What's up, bro?
What's up?"
He was huge, and I was like,
"Yeah, like, we should do
something funny."
And then, like, you know, he --
-Well, you're both tall dudes.
How tall are you?
-6'4".
-Yeah, that's tall.
And Pete's tall.
-Yeah.
-So to lift up a tall man --
that's --
And you're tall.
That's a big fall.
-I was -- You know what?
I think I was -- Subconsciously,
I think I let myself --
I was like, "'SNL,' how did you
not do a sketch with us?"
And I was like,
"30 seconds left to go.
I'll come up with something."
-Here's a sketch.
By the way, you crushed
that performance.
Both performances, by the way,
were fantastic.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I loved that you did something
different, and it was cool.
I want to talk about your movie.
This is "The Last Son."
Congrats on this.
You got to do something that
I am actually so jealous of.
You got to kick open
a saloon door.
-Over and over again.
But it wasn't --
It was never in the movie.
It was just off camera.
-No, it doesn't matter.
-We lived on set,
so I lived in the barbershop,
which was adjacent
from the saloon,
which held all the wardrobe.
Like, all the shots in
the movie are in this town.
It was beautifully shot,
but, like, you know,
there was always --
All the cast lived on there,
except for, like,
Sam Worthington.
I think he was method and, like,
lived in the woods or something.
-Wow!
-'Cause I never saw him
in the town,
except for when he was acting.
-You all lived in the town?
-But I lived in the barbershop.
And, so, every day, like,
the saloon doors
would just be calling my name.
Every day, I'd wake up
and I'd be like...
"Good morning!"
And everyone was like,
"God, five days in a row."
-That's a --
Weirdly, I don't know why,
but it's always been kind of
a dream of mine
to kick open a door.
-It's great.
It's not fun when you do it
16 days in a row.
-Yeah, but I don't know.
-For me, it was.
-But look at how cool --
You're much cooler than I am.
But, I mean,
I remember, in college,
I had a playlist of songs that
would be great
to kick doors open to.
-Cool.
-Yeah, and Number 1 was
"Misty Mountain Hop,"
Led Zeppelin.
It goes like...
[ Vocalizing ]
I'm like,
"Maybe what I'll do is,
I'll have someone
go into a bar,
play that on the jukebox,
and when it gets to
the right moment,
I go...
♪♪
And just, "What's up, man?!"
You know?
You go, "Oh, my gosh."
I never got to live that.
-Well, I know the place.
-The saloon?
-Yeah, I know the place.
We'll go one day.
-Alright, you tell me the bar,
and I'll go.
-Yeah, we'll bring The Roots
so it can be as cool
as what just happened.
-Can you tell everyone --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can you tell everyone
what the movie is about?
-Yeah, so, it's almost --
To me --
I mean, I don't want to
speak for the director.
He might be like,
"What are you doing?"
But, to me, it was almost
like Cronus, like,
the Greek mythology of
the father who eats his sons,
who they --
He's told one of his sons
is going to overthrow him,
so he eats all of his kids
so that they can't
overthrow him.
And it's the same thing
in this one.
Like, Sam Worthington
is the father.
He gets a curse where it's said
that one of his kin
is going to kill him,
so he goes
and he kills all of his kids.
And I'm the last one
that he has to kill.
And you got to find --
You got to watch the movie
to find out if --
-Yeah, what happens.
"The Last Son" right here.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Colson Baker in
"The Last Son."
Take a look at this.
-Nice to meet you.
You got a nice place here.
Ah, chin up, man.
You look good.
That's nice.
[ Horse neighs ]
Ma'am.
Take a kneel for me, sir.
-Ooh! I'm into that.
Colson Baker, a.k.a.
Machine Gun Kelly, everybody.
"The Last Son" is in
select theaters December 10th.
Will you please come back?
Whenever you'd like,
please come back to the show.
I think you're really fun.
-Okay, I'll just stay here.
-Alright, perfect.